the noise traffic and buzz of
afghanistan's capital has long been
fueled by its local markets but that is
changing
russia's invasion of ukraine is making
an existing food crisis even worse food
prices are rising and resources are
becoming increasingly scarce
with the war in ukraine european
countries turn to markets in kazakhstan
for us that means the price of wheat
flour and oil have soared
a united nations report says many people
have built up enormous debt to buy food
over the past few months and access to
seeds fertilizer and water for
irrigation is limited
we've seen an increase of up to nine
dollars for every sack of flour so we're
very much affected by the war between
russia and ukraine
poverty has been rife in afghanistan for
years with nearly 20 million people
facing acute hunger
but political instability low harvest
violence and shipping delays are adding
pressure on the country's wheat supply
and fuel prices and that's being made
worse as inflation affects goods and
markets across the world
prices are skyrocketing people have
limited income sources and they have to
reduce their purchases
international aid is restricted as
western governments remain weary of the
taliban
and a decree ordering women to wear
clothing that covers them from head to
toe in public as well as recent school
closures have intensified criticism
abroad
the world is trying to show that it's
dedicated to philanthropy and
humanitarian causes by distributing a
sack of flour and five kilograms of
edible oil but this has no positive
impact on the people
with afghanistan already facing
political and economic struggles soaring
food prices are now another challenge
for its people
katya lopezodayan al jazeera